what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the 10 deaths of wolverine
and man you guys were right about
waiting on this and just letting it
unfold before i pass judgment on whether
or not this is good or bad this issue
makes everything make sense right
everything makes sense because of like
this one issue it's kind of weird that
it took us four issues to get to this
point but it's so amazing here's the
thing right we didn't know well in the
beginning we didn't even know if this
like phalanx version of wolverine was
even human in the first place but then
we found out that it is wolverine from
the future but the big question that we
had to ask is why is wolverine from the
future being sent into the past to kill
maura mctaggart we assumed that it was
because of the idea that morgan
mctaggart at the end of inferno
basically had this plan to essentially
prevent mutants from coming into
existence but she was defeated by she
was basically turned back into a human
so seemingly all of her campaigns and
stuff there was only so much she could
do as a human being in order to
overthrow the mutant population but we
knew the war between humans and mutants
was inevitable at the end of the day
right machines were also going to become
a part of that what this does here is
this initially opens up with wolverine
and forge which is a really really cool
concept because it's kind of a testament
or at least a kind of a throwback a
callback to like the forge and bishop
relationship from like x-men the
animated series which i absolutely loved
i spotted this like right off the bat
but essentially what forge gives
wolverine is a seed for a curcumin gate
seemingly the last one right he calls it
their fail-safe he's like this is our
our last thing right like this is our
last ditch effort our one shot in order
to prevent this future from coming into
existence right the preserve mutants
being basically wiped from the the face
of the planet pushed the point of near
extinction right like the huge mutant
and machine and human war that takes
place along the line what forge ends up
doing here and and really kind of with
wolverine's permission is taking the
seed and planting it in his eye that way
it can essentially stay safe right
because remember wolverine's entire
skeleton is adamantium so you can't just
cut his head off and nobody would really
even know it was there in the first
place but following that what he says is
like you have to get out of here you
have to use a time portal you have to go
back to the past you have to find a way
to stop this future from coming into
existence and the only real glimpse that
we get is just one of those iconic
glimpses that you get over the course of
marvel comics when you're talking about
days of future past or days of future
present or something like that when you
basically have the sentinels descending
on to uh onto forge really and wolverine
the last of the mutants seemingly in
existence with the intention of
destroying them right forge is just
holding things off and so at that point
you switch over to the far flung future
right that the the whole scenario with
forge and wolverine is like the near
future so we can say maybe 50 years from
now whereas the far-flung future is
about a thousand years from now and more
mctaggart here of course is one part
machine and one part human and that's
when it all really begins to come into
play because what ends up happening is
wolverine of course when he's overcome
by mormon mctaggart and ultimately kind
of left for dead ends up pulling the uh
the seed out of his eye and creating the
curculin gate and that's what leads to
him going back into the past with the
intention of destroying more mctaggart
what this does is it basically
establishes how the machine war happened
in the first place right and i know it
seems a little ambiguous here i know it
seems a little weird but bear with me
here right because the next scene we get
is basically wolverine alongside dakin
and uh and gabby and x-23 basically
racing towards uh arnob shakladar in
order to stop him right in order to
defeat him and when they arrive on the
scene essentially morgan mctaggart's
already gone and when he interrogates
him wolverine is like where is she at
right i you know and and ultimately like
or at least initially shackled refuses
to spill the beans so what he ends up
doing or at least what wolverine ends up
doing is that where the kids are able to
incapacitate chocoladar wolverine ends
up basically spilling the beans on the
fate of his kits because we didn't know
exactly how it was that like gabby and
laura kinney and dakin all died but what
we end up learning is that dakin is
actually the first to fault that he's
killed by the sentinels when he's
completely incinerated by an energy
blast for gabby she's actually
de-powered by nimrod right her healing
factor is shut down and she's ripped in
half but as bad as their fates are the
fate of laura kinney is far worse than
that because laura kinney is the closest
thing anybody has to wolverine because
dakin and gabby and them their healing
factors aren't necessarily on the same
level but laura kinney's essentially is
the fate that's reserved for her is
she's tortured and experimented on for
years by post-humans literally her
organs are harvested all kinds of stuff
and the way she ends up dying is just by
pain right literally she just she she
experiences pain to the point that she
ends up succumbing to it and perishes
and like that's it right but she's just
used as a guinea pig and so ultimately
that's when wolverine is like that's the
fate that awaits them because of what
you're doing here and because of what
maura mchagert was doing so where is
maura mctaggart right i swear on my
children's graves if you tell me where
she is i will not kill you and so when
shakur dumps the information wolverine
and actually a really really cool change
of pace here ends up using his phalanx
based or i guess his technological base
claws to actually perform a kind of
lobotomy on shackledart which basically
wipes the last you know everything from
the last three issues or since his
original appearance here wipes all that
from his memory so he doesn't remember
anything about like more mctaggart or
any of that stuff now here's why this
matters and here's what's actually going
on here so the idea is that with more
mitch haggard having been defeated at
the end of inferno we didn't know how
the war came about essentially more
mctaggart is the basis behind
post-humans that technically the
children of the vault were the first of
the post-humans basically a blending
between cybernetics and human beings but
what they were just kind of existed
inside their vault they stayed there
time passed differently they may or may
not have emerged that when maura
mctaggart was given the phalanx arm by
warlock it dawned on her that the only
way to ensure the destruction of the
mutant race is to basically ensure that
the mutant race faces a foe that they
simply cannot overcome that in all the
lives that she had lived that when the
war came between humans and mutants that
yes mutants always lost but humans were
also destroyed as well but then you had
the post-humans so the idea of more
mctaggart is to basically work with
shakudor at least was to work with
shakudar and then find a way to merge
human beings and robots together that's
what creates the post-humans in the
house of powers of x storyline and
that's why it is eventually with the
phalanx technology and whatnot they
reach out to the phalanx race and the
phalace race deems them worthy and then
absorbs them into the covenant right
absorbs their consciousness basically
into a kind of technological hivemind
right true immortality is more a
mctaggart calls it right that's
literally how all this unfolds she's
ensuring the destruction of the mutant
race one way or another now if there
were ever any debate as to whether maura
mick haggard was a good guy or bad guy
this is laid to rest when she
essentially enters through a curcumin
gate now she's not supposed to be able
to do that remember humans cannot pass
through the gates only mutants only and
only mutants that have a mutant
genealogy or mutant genes that are
detected can pass through it what you
end up finding out here is that she had
basically killed uh sean cassidy right
she killed banshee and then stripped the
skin off his body and then put it on
herself and then used that to pass
through the cocoa and gates i mean
that's just diabolical man like that's
just that's just brutal
right i mean maybe it was kind of a
throwaway thing because she's kind of
like well i mean he can always be
resurrected but even then right throwing
away a life in such a crass manner is
just there's no room for remorse there
right no room for redemption there's no
way to look at that and to argue that
there's anything about it that's
beneficial now in terms of why she's
here the real motivation is that from
her perspective on the off chance that
shakladar will ultimately be found will
be captured and then will end up
divulging her information that she
wanted a backup plan and so her idea was
if the the gun of forge right the the
neutralizer gun had the ability to
basically shut down the powers of
anybody that's hit with its blast then
her thought was it can be reversed the
problem is when she gets her hand on
this gun xavier appears to her and is
like look that's not gonna work the way
that you think it is one like you can
still leave here but you can still walk
away we have a lengthy history together
i believe in gracoa even if you don't i
believe this mutant island can actually
serve a beneficial purpose aside from
just breeding mutants so that they will
ultimately be born with no powers
essentially just like creating
generation after generation after
generation of mutants each of which has
fewer powers than the last to the point
where there basically are no mutants
whatsoever that there has to be
something better than that but even if
you don't necessarily believe that's the
case because of our history like we can
just let you go right like you can just
leave i'm giving you a peace offering
more so than that i can give you cocoa
and medicines that will cure you of your
cancer more mctaggart i'm giving you a
second chance at your life you're not
immortal right like that gun is not
going to work the way that you think it
will it will not return your powers to
you so if you stay here you will die and
that will be the end of you if for
nothing else think of our history and
leave this place but ultimately because
she refuses to she's ambushed by forge
now the kicker to this is that she uses
her weapon on forge and strips forge of
his powers now here's the thing about
this right forge being a mutant can
basically be resurrected but if for some
reason he can't then krakowa loses their
version of tony stark because remember
the power of forge is that he basically
is tony stark he's exceedingly
intelligent when it comes to like
engineering machinery all that kind of
stuff right like he's the mutant version
of iron man but if he has no powers he
cannot be that guy the technological
advancements that have been made in
krakowa so far all go up in smoke they
just disappear because he's no longer
there anymore not only that once she
makes her escape and basically bails she
ends up just kind of dawning a sort of
uh suit of armor on herself right just
using a bit of cricoid tech at her
disposal that can really just kind of be
used by anybody but in the middle of all
this wolverine suddenly jumps back you
know after coming through the portal uh
leaving chocoladar behind and
immediately seizes after control of
maura mctaggart but more mig taggart
knowing that her fate is is basically
sealed knowing that she's seemingly
gonna die here ends up drawing the the
the neutralizer the the power
neutralizer and then fires it at
wolverine and when that happens it shuts
down his healing factor now under normal
circumstances that wouldn't matter but
remember wolverine's currently bonded
with phalanx tech and his healing factor
is the only thing that kept that phalanx
tech from basically bonding it to
himself this is incredibly important
because what this looks like is this
benjamin percy saying that future with
like the human machine and mutant war
and then humans basically working with
machines in order to turn themselves
into post-humans and then eradicate
mutants in their entirety that's a
guaranteed outcome before it was because
of more mctaggart and shackledart now
it's because the phalanx has totally
taken over wolverine and now that
machine component dominates and assuming
that the will of more mctaggart is the
will of the phalanx then it will most
likely spread and end up incorporating
humanity into itself and forming humans
anyway while simultaneously wiping out
the mutant population i am excited to
see where this goes yeah so thank you
guys great call i love this is one
reason why i love you guys so much you
guys are so good you guys are just like
no no no rob i know you're not really
feeling it just wait for it normally
that's what i do but with everything
going on with x-men it's after hickman
left i'm like i don't know how i feel
but thank you guys right you guys are
have been a godsend and telling me to
hold off so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace